I did want to mention this axios has a
story uh about a poll well it's a Gallup
poll that's getting a lot of attention
it's just pride and national identity is
the lowest among uh is is at a steep
decline they say it's lowest among those
18 to 34 illustrates the fracture
between Young Americans and older
Generations in the most recent Gallup
poll Americans 55 and older were nearly
three times more likely to be extremely
prideful of their nationality than
younger Generations
um overall 39 of us adults say that they
are extremely proud to be American in
the most recent poll meanwhile only 18
percent of those age 18 to 34 said the
same that they were proud to be American
or extremely proud compared to 40 of
those age 35 to 54 and 50 of those 55
and over so overall it's like a pathetic
picture I mean it's there's doesn't
appear to be a majority of people
extremely proud to be American
um in any age group
uh now in comparison in 2013 85 of those
aged 18 to 29 say they were extremely or
very proud to be an American
so I'll tell you the problem here and
it's yes it's true that younger
Generations are not instilled with any
kind of gratitude or patriotic love of
country and so on
but I'm not going to focus on that we've
talked about that before my problem with
this poll is that we're using extremely
proud to be American and patriotic
interchangeably
um where where we are pretending that
the way to find out if someone is
patriotic is to ask if they're proud of
America but I don't think that's true
I consider myself to be a patriot
but I am not proud of America right now
I'm not so you can cast your stones in
me if you want
if you must
but I'm not proud of America
I'm not proud to be an American at this
moment
did I still consider myself a patriot
and
I'll explain why I mean look at it like
this
if if I were to look around at my family
and I were to see that you know I don't
know my dad is a drug addict and my
mom's an alcoholic and I have a brother
in jail for embezzlement or something
none of this is true of my family by the
way just be clear but if it was
um if my family was just a mess with
everybody's lives and total disrepair
and everything is terrible
would I be proud of my family would I be
proud to declare myself a member of it
no I wouldn't because there's not much
to be proud of
I'd be embarrassed actually I'd be
pretty ashamed I'd be heartbroken to see
the state that my family is in but I
would still love my family as the point
in fact my love for my family would make
me even more ashamed and heartbroken and
embarrassed because I would want my
family and my family members to be
better people for their own sake I would
want my family to be in better shape
I love my family I want what's best for
it which means not blindly ignoring all
of these problems and just declaring
myself proud of everyone in the family
no matter if they act like a bunch of
scumbags or not that's not love of
family loving your family means that you
want to be proud of your family
it doesn't mean that you always are
it means that you want to be
same thing for your country to be a
patriot is to love your country to love
your country is to want your country to
be great which means first of all it
must be good
you want your country to flourish in
every way imaginable
it doesn't mean pretending that all of
those things are true when they aren't
so when I look around at America and I
see decaying cities and rampant crime
and absurd levels of corruption in
government and in all of our
institutions and kids being butchered
and mutilated and on and on and on uh
I'm not proud how could I be proud of
that
I'm embarrassed
um
I'm not proud of America right now
there's not much to be proud of I want
to be proud of the country okay and
that's why someone said why don't you
just leave no because this is my country
this is my home
I want it to be better than it is I want
to fight for it to be better
but I'm not going to pretend
that there's no problems to solve that
there aren't really deep and important
problems to solve I'm not going to
pretend that
and if you just declare that you're
proud of something or someone no matter
what
then your pride doesn't mean anything
it's like people say well I'm always
proud of my kids no matter what really
no matter what no matter what they do
you're proud of them
well then doesn't mean anything to say
that you're proud of them
so you're proud of your son whether he
comes home with an A on his report card
or you know he comes home with an F like
you're proud either way
so your pride in the good grade
apparently means absolutely nothing just
a default position that you've adopted
um
and that's not really Pride so yeah in
this case now I think a lot of those
people that say they're not proud of
America they probably would have very
different reasons you know for that they
probably explain their feelings in a
very different way but
I don't think that they're necessarily
wrong in how proud they see it thanks
for checking out this video if you'd
like to listen to my full podcast on the
go you can check out the Matt Walsh show
on Apple podcast Spotify or wherever you
get your podcasts